good afternoon this is a Lieutenant
General Joseph Costello commander of the
US Air Force of Central Command I'm
prepared to give a statement but I won't
be answering questions at this time a
u.s. navy rq-4 was flying over the Gulf
of Oman and the Strait of Hormuz on a
recent surveillance mission in
international airspace in the vicinity
of recent IRGC maritime attacks when it
was shot down by an IRGC surface-to-air
missile fired from a location in the
vicinity of garokk Iran this was an
unprovoked attack on a US surveillance
asset that had not violated Iranian
airspace at any time during its mission
this attack is an attempt to disrupt our
ability to monitor the area following
recent threats to international shipping
and the free flow of Commerce Iranian
reports that this aircraft was shot down
over Iran are categorically false the
aircraft was over the Strait of Hormuz
and fell into international waters at
the time of the intercept the rq-4 was
operating at high altitude approximately
34 kilometers from the nearest point of
land on the Iranian coast this dangerous
and escalatory attack was irresponsible
and occurred in the vicinity of
established air corridors between Dubai
UAE and Muscat Oman possibly endangering
innocent civilians thank you